Coffee on a Friday and the project for
awesome.
This is the earth.
It goes around the sun.
This is what it looks like up close.
This is America.
This is Los Angeles.
This is a school.
This is a classroom.
These are desks.
Here are some American children.
Here they are in class.
Here is there a teacher.
Here is one student being told that the
earth goes around the sun.
Here he is being told that there are 300
billion stars in the galaxy.
Here he is being told at one thimble
full of a neutron star would weigh over
$100,
million tons.
Here he is getting into mit.
Urias graduating magna cum louder.
Here he is.
Unraveling the mysteries of quantum
entanglement and understanding the key
to help plants collect,
store and use energy from the sun at 100
percent.
Efficiency here are super efficient.
Photo voltaic solar cells that his
physics helped to create.
Here they are powering the city.
Here they are powering a nation.
Here's the boy receiving the Nobel
prize.
Here he is on a Sunday afternoon with
his family.
Here he is thinking back over his life
about how everything he's done,
everything he is he owes to that first
science teacher who told him about the
earth and how it goes around the sun,
but the boy who is now an old man
wouldn't be wrong.
He's forgetting something,
something he would never think of.
Something that predicated the Nobel
prize in the solar cells and the physics
and mit and his excitement that day,
all those years ago about a thimble full
of neutron star.
Boy is forgetting the desks.
This is the earth again.
This is Africa.
This is a country in Africa called
Malawi.
This is a school.
This is a classroom.
There are no desks.
Here are some children in pain from
sitting on the dirt floor for eight
hours a day and here is one being told
that the earth goes around the sun.
Here is where I tell you that learning
is like a mountain.
It's hard at first to climb harder for
some,
but once you reach the peak and become
self perpetuating and fun and
transformative on and on for the rest of
your life,
here is how much it would cost to get
that boy a desk.
Here is how much it would cost to get
the whole classroom desks.
Here is how much you have to donate.
Here are what the desks look like.
Here are how many children the desks can
see.
Here are how many children usually sit
at one.
Here are how many children will sit at
your desk in its lifetime.
Here is the limit of what someone can do
when they love to learn.
Here is my charity.
Here is where you can read more about
it.
Here is where you can do it.